Louis Arbour bonjour merci de nous
accueillir chez vous avec plaisir dans
votre magnifique forêt c'est apaisant
puis je sais que vous en avez eu besoin
d'apaisement parce que vous avez des
sujets graves devant vous souvent dans
votre vie le fil conducteur bon exclus
Yougoslavie tribunal spécial cours
suprême ou commissaire au droit de
l'homme le rapport sur les inconduits de
sexuels agression sexuelle à l'armée
quel est le fil conducteur
je pense qu'il y en a
peut-être plus qu'un d'abord c'est
l'état de droit
ça c'est l'espèce de fil conducteur
professionnel puis peut-être le fil
conducteur qui s'ajoute à ça c'est la
pas une obsession mais la préoccupation
envers le but de pouvoir
et puis j'essaie de retracer d'où est-ce
que ça me vient là où est-ce que ça se
croise les deux mon intérêt évidemment
la justice la justice sociale droit à
l'État de droit et les problèmes d'abus
de pouvoir si j'essaie de retracer ça
moi je pense que ça me vient de la Loi
sur les mesures de guerre ah oui
l'origine de se dire que un état peut
devenir voyou un état peut exagérer un
état peu trop en faire il peut y avoir
une dérive puis là on peut se poser des
questions est-ce que c'est de bonne foi
est-ce qu'il y a des est-ce qu'il y
avait des motifs ultérieurs mais la
réalité c'est que un jour on est dans un
état de droit
puis tout à coup le pouvoir peu dérapé
et est-ce que vous avez une conclusion
sur la loi de l'époque la première fois
parce qu'on leur refait cette fois-ci
mais la première fois c'était abusif
selon vous ça a été ça a été un geste
une réaction politique dans tout le
contexte puis avec ce qu'on sait
maintenant
qui était probablement
moi je pense pas nécessaire puis qu'il y
a beaucoup ébranlé notre perception
comme société d'une société qui vit dans
un état de droit avec des garanties
c'est il y a eu beaucoup de gens arrêtez
de façon plus ou moins arbitraire
emprisonné sans on pensait pas que ça
pouvait se passer ici c'est là qu'on
voit que ça prend pas grand chose il
faut être très très vigilant des choses
peuvent basculer très rapidement l'état
peut rapidement prendre des mauvaises
habitudes vous parlez de gens qui ont
été arrêtés Jean Lapointe et décédés
récemment il a joué ce rôle magnifique
dans les ordres
l'incarne ça cette douleur là d'un
citoyen qui a rien fait arrêter qui vous
dites douleurs d'un citoyen qui se fait
arrêter mais c'est très difficile
d'imaginer l'état de panique dans lequel
on peut se trouver si on a plus de repas
si on peut pas se fier sur nos
institutions sur la confiance qu'on a
que ça peut pas nous arriver quand je
dis nous là il y en a plein de gens dans
notre société qui vivent constamment
avec cette inquiétude là
le profilage racial
sans tomber dans tous les exemples mais
il y a plein de gens même dans un état
de droit comme au Canada qui
a juste titre se sentent pas toujours en
sécurité vis-à-vis la possibilité de
l'abus de pouvoir donc pour vous les
chartes la charte canadien ça a été une
avancée extraordinaire
c'est ça les deux et particulier la
Charte canadienne surtout pour des
juristes de ma génération et on avait on
a étudié dans un environnement où
c'était pas ça le pouvoir judiciaire
c'est un pouvoir de deuxième ordre le
pouvoir d'interprétation puis là tout à
coup l'ancrage constitutionnel du
pouvoir judiciaire comme comme balise en
fait comme chez garde la démocratie
ça je trouve que c'est très dangereux de
commencer à utiliser ça à tout propos
mais en fait pour
occulter le rôle des tribunaux et de
l'utiliser en prévention j'imagine ces
pires à vos yeux comme on l'a dit NON
NON toute l'idée c'est bon d'abord les
gouvernements doivent avoir des
conseillers juridiques qui font une
analyse de la constitutionnalité des
lois et puis là il faut laisser tester
par des tribunaux puis après on fait les
ajustements possibles
la guerre Louise Arbour la directrice du
Centre ukrainien des libertés civiles a
dit ces jours-ci
si Poutine restait impunies ce sera une
victoire pour tous les dictateurs elle
prend pour une cour spéciale que l'on
forme rapidement est-ce que vous y
croyez
c'est pas évident je pense que c'est pas
étonnant le comédie mais c'est pas
évident comment ça pourrait être
constitué par exemple avant la Cour
pénale internationale moi les tribunaux
dans lesquels j'ai travaillé c'était le
tribunal pour l'exigoslavie pour le
Rwanda ça c'est des tribunaux qui
avaient été créés par le Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies c'est
impensable avec le droit de veto entre
autres de la Russie qu'on puisse avoir
un tribunal spécial pour l'Ukraine de la
même nature puis ces tribunaux là qui
étaient créés par le Conseil de sécurité
ils étaient très puissants parce que
c'est une espèce c'est un organe du
Conseil de sécurité donc on avait
beaucoup beaucoup de pouvoir mais ce que
les gens se posent en fait comme
question c'est est-ce que les crimes
encore une fois les crimes de guerre le
contre les civils seront punies ou pas
est-ce que vous imaginez vous qu'on va
développer quelqu'un un processus
d'abord il y a la justice ukrainienne
elle-même les crimes qui sont commis sur
son territoire que ce soit des meurtres
qu'on appelle un meurtre un crime de
guerre si c'est à grande échelle un
crime contre l'humanité ça va quand même
tomber sous la compétence des tribunaux
Ukrainiens il y a plusieurs pays qui ont
des compétences qu'on appelle des
compétences universelles donc si jamais
les auteurs présumés des crimes se
retrouvent par exemple en territoire
canadien mais on peut les juger même si
les clés ont été commis à l'étranger
bref je pense que il y a un éventail
d'options qui laisse croire que
l'impunité absolue
ça n'est plus de mise comment ça va
s'articuler ça va prendre combien de
temps ça c'est autre chose
et la question qu'on peut poser aussi
c'est les crimes commis par des milliers
ukrainiennes voilà on fait quoi avec ça
mais ça c'est toujours la même chose
c'est que les gens confondent parfois le
d'être dans la position juste dans une
gare par exemple en autodéfense le droit
de se défendre mais même quand on est la
bonne partie au conflit ça veut pas dire
qu'on peut faire n'importe quoi il y a
des contraintes sur la façon de faire la
guerre façon de traiter les prisonniers
la façon de traiter les civils le
gendarme qu'on peut utiliser puis ça ça
n'a rien à faire avec est-ce qu'on est
les bons ou les méchants dans dans la
guerre comme tel il y a beaucoup de
confusions là-dessus les gens prennent
parti disent c'est pas parce que les
Ukrainiens sont en position
d'autodéfense que tout leur est permis
que êtes-vous optimiste ou pessimiste
de manière générale quand vous regardez
la planète par rapport depuis le début
de vos intéressez à ça parce que quand
on parle de l'Ukraine on a l'impression
que tout va mal or tout ne va pas mal
êtes-vous plutôt pessimiste ou optimiste
vous en général je pense qu'en général
je suis très optimiste j'aurais pas pu
faire le genre de travail que j'ai fait
si j'étais paralysé par un espèce de
fatalisme pessimiste négatif au
contraire je pense que j'ai une énergie
très positive mais je suis très réaliste
aussi
ça ça dépend de ce qu'on sait quand on
parle des Nations unies par exemple on
occulte complètement le travail des
grandes agences c'est les agents sur le
terrain aussitôt qu'on se déplace donc
on arrive en Afrique ce qu'on voit des
Nations Unies c'est pas la paralysie du
Conseil de sécurité puis les tractations
politiques c'est le travail de l'UNICEF
du Programme alimentaire mondial c'est
les gens qui sont sur le terrain le des
équipes qui travaillent qui alors qui
ont fait reculer le seuil de la pauvreté
ils font des choses concrètes absolument
bon mais c'est intéressant parce que je
voulais vous poser cette question là sur
le nu vous êtes résolument
trop ONU malgré le fait qu'on voit
souvent comme une Mons qui est paralysé
où on met des pays comme l'Arabie
Saoudite mais ils avaient été
enlevé mais dans les comités des droits
de l'homme la Russie Cuba on se dit ça
se peut pas vous vous restez
résolument pour
absolument absolument
c'est le trop gros
les clubs de bien penser là autour
déterminé là c'est nous puis les autres
ça donne rien les vrais enjeux de notre
époque c'est des enjeux planétaires les
changements qui changement climatiques
ça prend un environnement dans lequel
tout le monde est à table
alors surtout proclamer le club des
biens pensants on va rien régler
d'ailleurs je pense que la
multiplication des autres forums j'ai 20
G8 G7 c'est bon mais il y a rien qui va
remplacer le forum où tout le monde est
là tout le monde a une voix la
conférence la Coop 15 sur la
biodiversité je suis contente que ça se
passe ici parce que je trouve que ça
donne aux gens un aperçu de Qu'est-ce
que ça a l'air 195 voies puis comment on
fait on a de la misère à écrire un texte
en équipe on est cinq six puis on peut
griffonner des heures de temps mais là
95 crayons là
ok donc mais le fait que des pays qui
bafoulent les droits de l'homme soit sur
des comités de droits de l'homme à l'ONU
ça vous choque pas ça il y a pas quelque
chose qui est antinomique
je pense qu'il faudrait juste regarder
parce que l'alternative il faudrait leur
faire passer un test de
comment ils sont bons dans les lois de
l'homme il y avait pas grand monde
honnêtement
parce que même des pays moi je pense
qu'ils ont quand même aussi
adéquat ou qui essaye de s'améliorer
comme le Canada par exemple parce que
l'important c'est de mesurer la
performance d'un pays vis-à-vis son
propre dossier ça sert à rien de mesurer
la Norvège avec la Chine ou le Canada
avec le SRI Lank l'important c'est de
regarder chaque pays puis de dire est-ce
qu'on est en
stagnation en régression ou en
progression ça ça peut être utile mais
sinon des périodes ça donne pas grand
chose parce que vous êtes pragmatique
là-dessus certains vous avez reproché
des militants en plus de dire elle elle
épargne lâchée elle est pas Intel pays
quand j'étais au droit de là vous dites
il faut être réaliste il faut garder un
dialogue pour reprendre le dialogue mais
moi je pense que ce qui est important il
faut être stratégique il faut se dire
qu'est-ce que je vais accomplir est-ce
que je veux
est-ce je pense sérieusement que la
dénonciation
ce qu'on appelle un name in shaming
qu'est-ce que ça fait ça me fait me
sentir bien ça fait plaisir à mes amis
alors le club est bien pensant va être
très content est-ce que l'autre côté va
complètement se braquer ou va céder il
faut être stratégique donc je reviens
sur le nu malgré la lourdeur de la
machine puis vous dites c'est inévitable
que ça soit lourd c'est inévitable ce
soit compliqué parce qu'ils sont tous là
mais il y a pas d'autres alternatives
pour vrai là le multi latéralisme c'est
la seule voie d'après vous ah oui il
faut il faut qu'il y ait un organe le
sait les Nations Unies où tout le monde
est à table
ouvrir la Charte des Nations unies par
exemple pour réformer le Conseil de
sécurité si l'organe le plus puissant on
en parle souvent mais de façon réaliste
est-ce que les cinq pays qui ont un veto
vont y renoncer est-ce qu'on peut les
forcer à renoncer et tous complètement
absurde pourquoi c'est 5 pays là la
France la Grande-Bretagne les États-Unis
le P3 comme on les appelle les permanent
3 puis la Russie puis la Chine de
l'autre côté mais oui le reste du monde
oui l'Argentine où il mais ça change pas
malheureusement non il faut dans le
moment ça change parce que c'est pas
réaliste de penser qu'on va changer ça
je passe à un autre sujet et vous avez
dit quelque part que c'était peut-être
aussi important que la crise climatique
sinon plus c'est la crise migratoire
vous avez fait un rapport important
là-dessus
quand monsieur blanken est venu au
Québec et au Canada il savait vous avez
pas idée à quel point vous touchez un
sujet peut-être le plus délicat le plus
important le plus massif
qu'on a devant nous la crise migratoire
vous êtes un peu de cet avis là c'est ce
qui nous guette si on n'arrive pas à
créer des couloirs légaux il faut
organiser parce que ça ne ça ne
diminuera pas la migration d'abord le
lien entre la mobilité humaine puis les
changements climatiques ça ne fait
qu'exagérer la difficulté d'une mouvance
migratoire qui est malgée et dans le
moment elle est pas bien gérée les
étonnantes des Nations Unies sont
toujours contents de parler de la
mobilité des capitaux la mobilité des
biens mais la mobilité des personnes ça
c'était ça relève exclusivement nous
disons de la souveraineté des États on
décide qui rentre chez nous qui en sort
qui peut y rester et il votre discussion
à y avoir mais je pense qu'on a vu
surtout après 2016 bon tous les
mouvements migratoires vers l'Europe qui
venaient de l'Afrique mais qui venait de
l'Afghanistan de la Syrie là on a
commencé à se rendre compte que il y a
pas un état qui peut gérer sa politique
migratoire sans parler aux autres des
frontières par définition ça implique
plus qu'un État puis on est encore on
est dans les balbutiements moi je pense
d'une vraie gestion intelligente non
seulement basée sur les droits
fondamentaux les droits humains mais sur
les intérêts économiques par exemple de
pays qui sont en déficit de
main-d'oeuvre à tout bien gérer ça au
niveau international on est au tout
début donc la pression veut s'accentuer
si on regarde cela pression sur les pays
du Nord s'accentuer puis devront
davantage collaboré ici avec notre
exemple shmeroxam on fait quoi d'après
vous vous voyez on n'arrive pas à
s'entendre avec les Américains on fait
quoi
on fait quoi je pense qu'on doit d'abord
respecter le droit international qui
nous dit que il faut accueillir des
demandeurs d'asile et traiter de façon
adéquate de leur demande fermer la
frontière c'est lorsque Trump voulait
faire c'est le soir parce que on va
construire un mur de Terre-Neuve avant
couvert je pense pas parce que ça veut
dire fermer la frontière ferme un
robinet s'il va s'ouvrir ailleurs dans
un sens c'est mieux de le gérer tout en
même place parce qu'à Roxane c'est quand
même organisé les gens arrivent on leur
dit vous avez pas le droit de rentrer si
vous rentrez vous allez être arrêté ils
sont pris en charge demande d'asile mais
si on ferme ça puis commence à si vous
êtes allés dans cette région là je
rentre pas par le chemin Roxane 200
mètres plus loin s'il y a pas il y a pas
de clôture il y a pas de variante et
dans des champs ça c'est juste ici et
tout le long de la frontière c'est une
frontière qui est pas militarisée qui
est pas sécurisé mais est-il normal que
ça prenne jusqu'à deux ans pour que le
gouvernement fédéral réponde à ces
gens-là vous pouvez ou pas et de là des
gens disent c'est un contournement de
l'immigration légale c'est c'est
la gestion là si on tombe là dedans
c'est un gouvernement qui est pas
capable de mettre des passeports à ses
propres citoyens ça m'étonne pas
beaucoup
on est dans une bureaucratie à tous les
niveaux au niveau de la gestion des
services de santé la gestion de la
justice des tribunaux on est en espèces
de déficit de performance à tous les
niveaux de service ce qui est assez
étonnant considérant qu'on paye quand
même beaucoup d'impôts on est des
sociétés bien organisées mais je sais
pas le gestionnaire de formation mais
c'est assez étonnant et presque pas un
seul secteur pas les transports la
justice la santé
où on peut dire que ça roule ça vaut
rien on a toute une population qui est
dans une espèce de clandestinité à cause
de déficience qui sont là très très
souvent purement du requêtes
et vous trouvez j'imagine que le
discours vis-à-vis ces gens-là en
général les Naples les nouveaux
arrivants qui sont et trop négatif
c'est très négatif puisqu'il est
hallucinant quand on se penche sur ces
questions là c'est à quel point tout ça
la négativité c'est issu d'une série de
préjugés qui sont complètement profondé
par exemple que si on demande aux gens
bon les migrants illégaux qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez l'image ça c'est le
langage véhicule illégal c'est comme
criminel terroriste dangereux la réalité
c'est que la plupart des gens qui sont
dans une situation d'irrégularité
d'avoir son rentrée au pays de façon
régulière tout à fait légal puis
l'abeille
ils ont fait face à des obstacles
techniques même chose c'est la même
chose partout l'autre espèce de préjugés
c'est que tout le Sud de la planète
voudrait déménager au nord ce qui est
assez bizarre considérant notre climat
c'est évident que c'est pas le cas mais
c'est pas vrai il se déplace d'abord à
l'interne puis après il se déplace dans
le pays voisin il s'en vont pas tous en
Allemagne et puis aux États-Unis en tout
cas c'est un sujet qui divise on le vu
au Québec dans dernière campagne
électorale on l'a vu en Europe on le
voit en France on voit partout c'est un
sujet qui divise mais on l'a vu quand
l'Europe la solidarité européenne
s'était fluide à part l'Allemagne qui
était un pays vraiment un pays d'accueil
à tous les niveaux réfugiés migrants
économique mais l'Italie la Grèce se
sont sentis juste titre être sur les
premières lignes puis à personne en
arrière 2 pour dire là c'est un projet
européen un continent de 500 millions
d'habitants devraient être capable
d'absorber un million qui frappe à la
porte on regarde juste le million qui
arrive aux frontières mais un million
sur 500 millions là le principe ça gère
il faut que tout le monde fasse la danse
voilà
Louis Arbo vous êtes aussi penché sur
les agressions sexuelles dans l'armée
rapport récent inconduite et agression
sexuelle de manière générale j'ai
constaté que le changement de culture au
sein des forces armées a très peu de
chances de se produire si l'organisation
continue d'insister sur une autonomie
totale quel regard par ailleurs vous
portez sur tout ce mouvement
justice populaire ce mouvement d'abord
de Me Too qui est libéré la parole que
planétaire puis ensuite
de ça découler une espèce de justice
populaire sur les réseaux sociaux vous
comme juriste ça doit vous ça doit aller
vous chercher ça oui je pense que ça va
peut-être redonner à la justice certaine
de ces lettres de noblesse on a beaucoup
critiqué la performance des tribunaux
particulièrement en matière de d'un
contenu sexuel tout ce qui est rattaché
à juste titre toutes sortes de règles
qui étaient basées justement sur des
stéréotypes culturelles de l'époque bon
on a évacué tout ça
mais on reste dans un système de droit
dans lequel puis moi je continue d'y
croire la règle fondamentale c'est qu'il
est c'est mieux que 10 coupables évitent
un châtiment plutôt que de risquer de
condamner un innocent ça on y croit où
on y croit pas moi j'y crois c'est ça le
doute raisonnable c'est ça encore le
débalises contre les possibles dérives
de l'abus de pouvoir c'est ça le système
judiciaire mais avec la justice
populaire sans qui est
cette espèce de garde de fou là pour
vraiment déterminer le niveau de
responsabilité
mais l'on peut avoir des peines qui font
que des gens peuvent plus travailler
il y a plus de justice
alors peut-être que ça ça va se
rééquilibrer je le sais que c'est
difficile pour des gens des fois de lire
un jugement ou le juge dit c'est pas que
je ne crois pas la plaignante je la
crois mais je vis dans un système où le
doute raisonnable c'est ça c'est le
c'est le garde de fou le qu'on va pas à
l'autre extrême donc j'avais encore puis
on boucle la boucle vous dites ce qui
m'a fait entrer dans cette dans cette
aventure là c'est quand l'État se donne
trop de droit par rapport aux citoyens
l'abus de pouvoir
le système de justice fonctionne quand
même assez bien selon je pense qu'il
fonctionne très bien au niveau de
l'élaboration des normes où il
fonctionne moins bien puis ça on en
entend parler de façon régulière c'est
encore au niveau de la livraison des
Services mais au niveau de la justice
moi je pense que la qualité des normes
la qualité de la jurisprudence la
qualité des jugements qui sont rendus
qui sont réfléchis et
les tribunaux d'appel
contrairement à ce que moi j'avais vu le
quand j'étais étudiante en droit ça ça
s'est beaucoup amélioré c'est c'est au
niveau de livrer le service on est
déficitaire dans tous les secteurs
Louis Arbour qu'est-ce que un terminat
qu'est-ce qui vous anime que c'est quoi
votre prochain moteur votre prochain
défi
je me cherche pas de job
vous avez donné non non mais j'ai encore
occupé là je siège par exemple sur le
conseil d'administration de la Fondation
MasterCard qui est une qui est pas très
connue qui est une grande Fondation
canadienne
où on travaille
surtout en Afrique mais un petit peu
aussi dans les populations autochtones
au Canada c'est une des plus grandes
fondations au monde au niveau de ses
effectifs alors je fais encore beaucoup
de choses comme ça donc je vais en
Afrique encore la série régulièrement
ce soir je travaille un petit peu
encore du droit ça ça me c'est fascinant
vous entendre Louise Arbour merci
beaucoup pour cette entrevue
joyeuses fêtes à vous aussi